but Nuggets starting line whoa a jump  ball but what a pass by all around  Yogesh Wow work got in there to contest  work a great excellent defender and  really good athlete and he's good with  me for a long time  and why st. me say wolves and links  that's Paul Swanson  Bart steps back for three  still home free just a second decide not  to Garlin he steps back in 95 seconds  remaining  Millsap okay  he'd have made the two free-throws that  you've missed here in the last three  minutes it'd be a tie game but a nice  little run late nine straight points for  the Nuggets here if you'd have made the  two free throws that you've missed here  in the last three minutes 95 seconds  remaining  Barton  [Applause]  honestly  ninety six ninety it just made a step  back miss it but how about Millsaps  running it down memory all twined step  back sort come out of nowhere Paul  Milsap  Marie it just made a step back miss it  but how about Millsaps running it down  and Marie got his hand on